Host: Well, thanks everyone and welcome again
to Authors@Google live in the San
Francisco office. Today, uh, we have Steven
Hall talking about his book,
"Wisdom, from Philosophy to Neuroscience".
Umm, award-winning science writer
Steven Hall examines ancient concepts of wisdom
through the lens of modern brain
science and -- and neuroscience. Uh, breaking
wisdom down to what Steven refers
to as the eight neural pillars, uh, Hall takes
a fresh look at human qualities
long associated with wisdom including compassion,
emotional regulation, the
ability to discern what's important, uh, and
the skill of coping with
uncertainty and suggests that modern neuroscience
is providing radical new
insights about how these timeless virtues
evolved. Uh, based in part on a 2007
article in the New York Times Magazine, umm,
which I strongly recommend looking
up and reading, "Wisdom" is also a meditation
on the seeds of wisdom, aspects of
wisdom if our everyday life, and the future
of wisdom in our complex society.
Hall is a professor of journalism at Columbia
and NYU and he actually has an
article coming out a little later this month
in "National Geographic". So be
sure to check out, if you'd like to know more,
his web site, Stevenshall.com
where he has a nice new blog known as "Mind-Wise."
So thanks again. Let's
welcome Steven Hall to Google.
>> [Applause]
>> [Pause]
Stephen: Great. Thank you very much for inviting
me here to talk about this.
Umm, uh, I'm gonna give you a little bit of
background in how I got involved in
this. Umm, "Wisdom" is obviously an immense
topic, umm, and it's kinda
difficult to talk about because it means so
many different things to different
people and the definition has changed over
the course of history and the
definition has been argued about for the last
2500 years. Umm, and even as I'm
beginning I can imagine several pertinent
questions running through your minds,
uh, most obvious of which is what exactly
does he mean by wisdom? And who the
heck is this guy to be telling me about it?
Those are both good questions and
I'm gonna answer the second one first because
A it's easier but B it actually
kinda tells you the story of how I got involved
in this. Umm, I'm not a
philosopher. I hope that's obvious. Lord knows
I'm not a theologian. I was
the only kid in my high school class who flunked
the test on the Bible which is
not easy. I'm not a psychologist and I'm certainly,
uh, not a neuroscientist.
Uh, I'm a science writer and for the last
25, 30 years I've mostly written about
very basic science. I write a lot about genetics;
I write a lot about molecular
biology; uh, I write about immunology; I've
written histories of the creation of
biotechnology, how the -- how the entire industry
was actually founded a few
miles south of here in South San Francisco
with Genentech, umm; I've written a
book about cancer immunotherapy. So it's been
really basic science that always,
you know, intrigued me and then also the history
and story behind these things.
Uh, so then the question is, so, uh, what
in the world attracted me to the topic
of wisdom which is very much unlike those
other topics? Umm, and the answer to
that is it kinda began with a phone call that
I received in the fall of 2006.
Umm, the call was from, uh, my editor at the
New York Times magazine, a woman by
the name of Vera Titunik who explained at
the magazine was doing a special issue
on the baby boomer generation getting old
and would I like to contribute to it.
Umm, I'm not sure exactly what qualified me
for the call but I suspect part of
it was my inclusion in that generation. Umm,
but in point of fact I've
actually -- I did my very first cover story
for the "Times Magazine" in 1981 so
I've had a fairly steady association with
the magazine for nearly 30 years; have
worked in the magazine; have been the science
editor of the magazine, umm, and
have done a number of stories so I kinda think
of it as a kind of home that I'm
always delight and had kind of flattered when
they get in touch and ask me if
I'd be interested in doing something. So I
said do they have anything in
particular in mind and, uh, she said yes.
They had heard that there was
research that had been conducted in wisdom
and would I be interested in writing
about this. Umm, and contrary to the -- what
you might think because of the
book that's sitting in front of you, my first
sort of reaction is my heart
completely sank when I heard this 'cause I
thought, uh, there's no way this --
there's no way there could be any credible
science that is associated in this
and there's no way research could be, uh,
could be credible. Umm, I can tell
you this but I didn't tell her that. The whole
idea of it because it's such a
nebulous idea, how do you define wisdom, how
could you conduct empirical
research on it was kind of ridiculous. Umm,
and again for the same reasons I
just mentioned I spent my whole career writing
about hard science and in
addition the critical thinking that produces
hard science and the notion that
something is nebulous and fuzzy as wisdom
could lend itself to empirical study
really struck me as preposterous. Fortunately,
I didn't actually tell her that.
>> [Laughing]
Stephen: Uh, instead, I said, uh, I would
look into it and she said, great.
And she mentioned a couple of psychologists
who had done some of this research,
umm, and when she mentioned it I said that's
interesting and since it was a
phone call she didn't seem me rolling my eyes
as I said, "That's interesting"
and then I started gathering the research
and started, umm, just kind of
involving myself and immersing myself in this
literature. So what was this
literature? Well, it turns out very interestingly
that in the 1970s and the
1980s, umm, there was a small group of psychologists
kind of inspired by Eric
Ericson, who is a name you might recognize
as one of the great 20th century
American psychologists, umm, who began a kind
of formal study of wisdom and
Ericson had glancingly mentioned wisdom very
early on in his career, actually at
around 1950, umm, as a kind of culminating
stage of human development toward the
end of life. Part of his definition was it's
reconciliation of two kind of
opposite things, one of which was what he
called "ego integrity" which is kind
of being settled into one's self at that stage
of life and the disruption of
contemplating one's mortality. So there are
these two con -- conflicting
impulses going on toward the end of life and
wisdom kind of manifested itself
and you were able to reconcile these two things
and continue, uh, forward and be
productive. Umm, it also coincided interestingly
with a -- with a tangent from
gerontology. For a lot of gerontology and
gerontological psychology to that
point, uh, people mostly studied mental decline
and physical decline. Those
were the things that were associated with
aging and in the 1970s a group of
psychologists said there must also be some
positive things about aging. Why
don't we go out and look for them? Umm, there
was a group at University of
Southern California led by a pretty prominent
gerontological psychologist named
James Birren kind of initiated a lot of this
study and it was one of his
graduate students, a woman named Vivian Clayton
who lives in Berkeley, umm, who
did the first even faintly empirical studied
of wisdom. They were published in
1975. And as I learned, as I started familiarizing
myself with this early
history, the researchers who actually started
looking at this were not flakes.
They were very mainstream people in psychology.
One of them, uh, was a guy
named Robert Sternburg, who is a professor
at Yale University for 30 years.
Very, umm, well known for theory of intelligence
and in fact he then went into
wisdom research because he, uh, felt that
the, uh, intelligence as a theory was
flawed because it didn't take into account
certain aspects of human behavior
that didn't rise to the level of wisdom. So
he actually used the -- uh,
intelligence to get to wisdom. Umm, he's a
former President of the American
Psychological Association so he's very mainstream
in that sense. Uh, and then
there was a group based in Germany at the
Max Plank Institute for Human
Development led by Paul Baltes. They, too,
had been studying aging and had an
aging project in Berlin in the 1980s that
morphed into the Berlin Wisdom Project
because they became really intrigued by how
elderly people were dealing with
some of these issues and what constituted
wisdom, how one acquired it and how it
developed. So these were not fringe figures.
They were actually very
interesting mainstream psychologists probably
well established enough to take on
this crazy idea of wisdom because there was
a lot of obvious skepticism much
like I had. Umm, many of these people came
from a field known as, uh, lifespan
developmental psychology which is a branch
of psychology which studies changes
in human development, thought, emotion over
the course of the lifetime with the
understanding that the times you live in,
the, uh, events that happened, the
technologies that are available, everything
that occurs during your lifetime has
an impact on how you think and how you feel
and how those qualities evolve and
change over the course of a lifetime. I mean,
it sounds very obvious to us now
but in fact so much psychology was based on
specific time periods and sort of
the present tense so it it can a much broader
view of it. So anyway, this small
group of researchers started to design studies
and they began publishing studies
about wisdom beginning again around 1975 and
enough had been, uh, published that
in 1990 there was actually an academic anthology
edited by Sternberg entitled
"Wisdom". So I got my hands on this book and
I started reading these, uh, uh,
articles, umm, and it really kind of explains
how I got into this. A funny
thing happened. Umm, I really found myself
fascinated by this very fuzzy topic.
Again, most of the research I read and write
about is -- involves transcription
factors in genetics and the nuts and bolts
of antigen and antibody technology,
very, very detailed mechanistic explanations
of how things work at a reductive
level. Umm, suddenly I was reading about life
choices, moral decisions and
moral judgment, emotional resilience and resolving
problems that often resolved
these kind of timeless conflicts between the
immediate impulse to satisfy one's
urges and delaying those gratifications to
get a larger goal on the one hand or
try to mediate the self-interest versus what
would be of interest to a larger
group of people whether it's a family, congregation,
work group, whatever --
whatever it is. Umm, I found the reading incredibly
stimulating in part because
it did what all us writers want our work to
do which is it got me to stop and to
think and the stopping part of it was as important
as the thinking part of it.
>> [Pause]
Stephen: As I continued to read and do things
I noticed that there were kind of
changes in my own pattern of behavior and
thought that were really kind of
interesting. Umm, whenever I read about wisdom
and it definition I found myself
sort of arguing with the definition, troubleshooting
the def -- definition,
disputing the definition but at the same time
being illuminated by that kind of,
uh, disagreement and just thinking about,
uh, not only wisdom but then how it
kind of resonated with the decisions that
I had made in my own life, the kind of
choices I'd made, that sort of thing. In a
funny sense, the definition of
wisdom began not even to matter too much.
It's important, obviously
scientifically, but, umm, Sternberg made the
point that to understand wisdom
fully and correctly probably requires more
wisdom than any of us have. So
there's an understanding that -- that whatever
we're talking about is difficult
to get our arms around but I don't think that
means that it's not worth thinking
about or not even worth trying to define but
we -- we -- we gravitate towards
certain, umm, qualities. Now, granted that
wisdom is almost, uh, impossible to
define and that book I mention that came out
in 1990 by the psychologist, umm,
had 13 chapters written by 13 different groups
of psychologists and every
chapter had a different definition of -- of
wisdom. And it just sort of
indicates the kind of -- there's no definitional
consensus in many ways about
what actually it is. Umm, but and this is
what -- another sort of part of this
process -- I began to pay more attention to
the convergences and the congruences
of the definition than I did about the differences
and there were things that
were congruent across different definitions.
Umm, there were certain cognitive
qualities and emotional traits that kept cropping
up again and again in these
discussions primarily in the psychological
literature but also in the
philosophical literature. Things like being
even-keeled emotionally and how
that sort of prepared you for decision making;
an ability to frame problems in a
way that allows you to see alternative solutions;
an ability to understand the
viewpoint of others, uh, an ability to weigh
future rewards against, uh,
immediate -- the allure of immediate gratifications,
a sense of moral and social
justice; an ability to deal with limitation,
uncertainty, and change. These
qualities ran through a lot of discussions
of wisdom whether it was in
psychology and if you go back and look in
the early history of philosophy as
well. And this kinda led to the second sort
of major insight. Umm, I knew that
no one in neuroscience was seriously doing
research in wisdom but I realized
that a lot of cutting edge neuroscientific
research was being done on precisely
these cognitive and emotional qualities that
I had kind of identified, umm, and
in fact psychologists, thee low gins, philosophers
long before me had identified
as being, umm, really important if not central
to wisdom. If I bring anything
special to this whole enterprise, uh, I kind
of have always had the dumb luck of
being familiar with a lot of different fields
that don't typically talk to each
other. So I was able to see conversations
that were in different fields that
maybe they were not aware of. Uh, clearly
the neuroscience community was not
aware of this wisdom literature, uh, the wisdom
community -- the wisdom
psychologists were actually not that aware
of the neuroscience. Umm,
neuroscience, interestingly, was becoming
very conscious of some of the very old
arguments philosophically so they were beginning
to pay attention and one of the
most interesting phenomena I've observed in
the last five years in the
scientific literature: Very hard core articles
in nature and science about
brain, uh, neuroscience is that the list of
citations at the end of the article
include people like Aristotle, uh, John Stuart
Mills, John Rawls, umm, David
Hume. In other words, these ancient conflicts
that have been identified and
bandied about for centuries if not millennia
are being re-examined, readdressed,
and different experimental protocols are being
designed to kind of test them in
the sort of atmosphere of brain science now
which is, in and of itself, really
interesting. So that got me to ask these questions.
So can the workings of the
brain help us understand what it means to
be wise and perhaps even suggest ways
we can become wiser? Uh, is there any place
for wisdom in our modern world?
And of course before answering those questions
I had to come the at least a
tentative answer to one other question which
is again, what exactly is wisdom?
Umm, I'm not gonna answer that too specifically
but I'm gonna give you an
example of how one comes kind of sideways
into some of these issues. Umm, uh,
it's a question that has so many dimensions
as I mentioned before but also
because the book actually runs through a number
of working definitions and, umm,
you know, argues with them, uh, announces
them and it's -- I think part of the
processing of wisdom is processing one's definition
of it in thinking how it
applies to you and that's part of the process
of this entire book. However,
umm, I really like the succinctness of a contemporary
author, Robert Nozic, who
said, wisdom is an understanding of what is
important. And there's a lot of
stuff that follows behind that very simple
statement, how we determine
valuation, how we value what's important,
what's the -- the ambit or environment
of importance? How do we gather knowledge
that reinforces what's important, so
on and so forth? But that specific standard
I think is really important and
that leads me to an episode in my own life
with which I begin the book because
it occurred to me much after the fact that
it was an exercise in deciding what
was important even though at the time I was
actually not aware of it. So I'd
just like to read the kind of beginning of
the book as an example of how our
brain works at least. Umm, okay. On a beaut
-- On a beautiful fall morning
nearly a decade ago, like hundreds of mornings
before and since, I dropped off
one of my children at school. Micaela, then
five years old, had just started
first grade, and the playground chatter among
both the children and their
parents reflected that mix of nervous unfamiliarity
and comforting reconnection
that marks the beginning of the school year.
I lingered in the schoolyard until
Micaela lined up with her teacher and classmates.
She wore a pretty purple
dress that my mother had just sent her, white
socks, and
pink-and-white-checkered sneakers. A hair
band exposed her hopeful, eager,
beautiful face. I sneaked in a last hug, as
impulsive dads are wont to do,
before she disappeared into the building.
The time was about 8:40 a.m. As I
left the schoolyard and began to head toward
the subway and home to Brooklyn, I
heard a thunderous, unfamiliar roar overhead.
As the noise grew louder and
closer, I froze in an instinctive crouch,
much like the rats we always read
about in scientific experiments on fear, wondering
where the sound was coming
from, knowing only that it was ominously out
of the ordinary. Moments later, a
huge shadow with metal wings passed directly
over my head, like some prehistoric
bird of prey.
>> [coughing]
Stephen: Excuse me. I instantly recognized
it as a large twin-engine
commercial airliner, but nothing in my experience
prepared me for what happened
next. I watched for the endless one … two
… three … four seconds it took for
this shiny man-made bird -- excuse me -- to
fly directly into the tall building
that I faced several blocks away. In real
time, I watched a 395,000-pound
airplane simply disappear. Almost immediately
black smoke began to curl out of
the cruel, grinning incision its wings had
sliced in the façade of the
skyscraper. In moments when life’s regular
playbook flies out the window, when
the ground shifts beneath our feet in a literal
or figurative earthquake, we
feel a surge of adrenalized fear at the shock
of the unexpected. But right
behind that feeling comes the struggle to
make sense of the seemingly senseless,
to try to understand what has just happened
and what it means so that we will
know how to think about a future that suddenly
seems uncertain and
unpredictable. In truth, the future is always
unpredictable, which is why these
moments of shock remind us, with unusual urgency,
that we have a constant (if
often unconscious) need for wisdom, too. Although
we now know -- we now all
know exactly what happened that terrible morning,
the ground truth in lower
Manhattan on September 11, 2001, was much
fuzzier at 8:45 a.m. One of the
hallmarks of wisdom, what distinguishes it
so sharply from “mere” intelligence,
is the ability to exercise good judgment in
the face of imperfect knowledge. In
short, do the right thing -- ethically, socially,
familiarly, personally.
Sometimes, as on this day, we have to deliberate
these decisions in the midst of
an absolutely roaring neural stew of conscious
and unconscious urgings. In one
sense, I knew exactly what had happened long
before the first news bulletin hit
the airwaves. In a larger sense, someone watching
television in Timbuktu soon
knew vastly more about the big picture than
I did. This may be an exaggerated
example, but it is in precisely the murk of
this kind of confusion that we often
have to make decisions. So what did I do?
I went to a nearby shop and bought a
cup of coffee. It didn’t occur to me until
much later that this was a decision
of sorts -- perhaps a foolish one, and certainly
not an obvious one. But to the
extent that I mustered even --
>> [coughing]
Stephen: Excuse me -- a dram of wisdom that
day, it was in how I viewed the
situation and what I thought was most important.
Oddly, I felt little or no
physical threat, despite such close proximity
to the unfolding disaster; in some
respects, the event played much scarier on
TV than in person. My person -- My
immediate focus, even then, was on the long-term
psychological impact that such
a calamity might have on a young child, and
what (if anything) a parent might do
to minimize it. I hadn’t quite understood
yet that that would be my mission for
the day, but by standing in the street and
sipping a cup of coffee, in that
mysterious shorthand of human choice, I had
chosen to stay close to my daughter,
to stay calm, and, failing that, to fake parental
calm realistically enough to
convince her that this was a situation we
could deal with. But she didn’t need
to see the whole movie. I did not think it
was a good idea for a young child to
witness, as I did, human bodies falling like
paperweight angels from the upper
floors of the nearby tower. Even more, I did
not think it was a good idea for a
young child to absorb, even for a moment,
the panic and despair written on the
faces of all the adults who were beginning
to comprehend that the world as they
had known it, even a few minutes earlier,
had suddenly changed, slipping
irrevocably out of their (however illusionary)
controlling grasp. If you’re
thinking that I’m offering a smug little
narrative about wise parenting, not to
worry. Wisdom doesn’t come easily to us
mortals, and I’ve been reminded many
times since that it probably didn’t come
to me that day, either. Many of the
choices I made that morning were second-guessed
by my wife, by my friends, and
even by my daughter. More to the point, my
small-minded plan to buffer
Micaela’s emotional experience was rudely
interrupted by the collapse of 500,000
tons of metal, concrete, and glass. Just as
teachers began to evacuate children
from the school, the second tower came down,
unleashing the kind of apocalyptic
roar no child should ever have to hear, and
a huge pyroclastic cloud of debris
came boiling up Greenwich Street toward us.
You couldn’t tell if the cloud was
going to reach us or not, but it wasn’t
a moment for contemplation. I picked up
Micaela and we joined a horde of people running
up the street. As I carried her
in my arms, swimming upriver in a school of
panicked fish, she was forced to
look backward, downtown, right into the onrushing
menace of our suddenly dark
times. Even to this day, however, the thing
Micaela remembers most about the
evacuation is the moment her classmate Liam
accidentally walked into a street
sign when he wasn’t looking. It will be
a long time, if ever, before I know if
I acted wisely on 9/11. Indeed, it didn’t
even occur to me until I was writing
this passage that the most important decision
I made that day did not even rise
to the level of conscious choice. I “decided,”
without any conspicuous
deliberation, that I had to be a parent first,
not a journalist, on that
particular morning. At one level, it was an
obvious choice; at another, it went
against self-interest, career, my professional
identity, taking advantage of
being an eyewitness to the biggest story of
my lifetime. What was I thinking?
That, in a sense, is what I want this book
to be about: How do we make complex,
complicated decisions and life choices, and
what makes some of these choices so
clearly wise that we all intuitively recognize
them as a moment, however brief,
of human wisdom? What goes on in our heads
when we’re struggling to be patient
and prudent, and are there ways to enhance
those qualities? When we’re being
foolish, on the other hand, do our brains
make us do it? And how does the
passage of time, and our approaching mortality,
change our thought processes and
perhaps make us more amenable to wisdom? In
moments of exceptional challenge
and uncertainty, we tend to ask, How did this
happen? What could we have done
to prevent this dire turn of events? This
is another way of saying, I realize
now, that we are always searching for wisdom,
but all too often we are looking
for it in the rearview mirror, sifting the
past for clues to how we might have
thought about the future in a different way.
We crave wisdom -- worship it in
others, wish it upon our children, and seek
it ourselves -- precisely because it
will help us lead a meaningful life as we
count our days, because we hope it
will guide our actions as we step cautiously
into that always uncertain future.
At times of challenge and uncertainty, nothing
seems more important than
wisdom -- economic wisdom, moral wisdom, political
wisdom, even that private,
behind-closed-doors wisdom that allows us
to convey the gravity of changed
circumstances to our children without making
them afraid of change itself.
Nothing seems more important, yet nothing
seems more beyond our grasp, until we
begin to think about wisdom before we think
we need it. So I wanted to read
this as an example of -- of the kind of decision
making we sometimes make
without being aware of it. Umm, we're not
-- uh we're unconscious of the
process, uh, and there's been a lot of neuroscience
in the last ten or 15 years
that's made clear that the emotional part
of our brain is kind of telling us
sometimes things to do and counseling our
actions at a level that we're not even
conscious of until later. Umm, I would say
that that counsil is not always wise
which is what makes it kind of tricky and
interesting but none the less it's an
input to behavior and thought that I think
is much more appreciated now than it
used to be. Umm, and it's also kind of a reminder
that we're always struggling
to be wise and to do the right thing. But
what's exactly going on inside our
brains when we're doing there and is there
any reason to think we might possibly
become wiser if we understand the neural underpinnings
of wisdom? So I set out
to see if I could attach any serious science,
uh, to if not wisdom itself to
these qualities or traits that seemed important
to the idea of wisdom as I was
conducting this research. And the -- my approach
was the following. Umm, as
many of you probably know, the great power
of modern science is something called
"reductionism." You basically take a big biological
idea, for example, like
heredity, and then you break it down into
some component part which is then you
can approach experiment tally and design experiments
about and hopefully get
some answers to. Umm, in a more metaphoric
sense, uh, I took the same
reductionist approach to wisdom. The idea
itself is huge again and it doesn't
lend itself to easy description but I asked
myself, are there some common
elements in the definitions of wisdom that
might be reducible and is there any
real science to these elements? I should say
that when I started out doing this
I was hard pressed to find a single scientist
who would say she or he was
working on the neuroscience of wisdom and
for very good reason. Umm, people
wouldn't think you were a very good scientist
if you attempted to measure a
process that you could not even define. So
it was not an active interest of any
neuroscientist I talked to at the time. However,
when you break wisdom down
into some of its component parts, when you
reduce it, which I did by kinda
following the lead of the psychologists, I
realized that there was a lot of
interesting research and I kind of organized
it for the purposes of the book and
somewhat arbitrarily into what I call the
"eight pillars of wisdom", kind of
building off the classic seven pillars of
wisdom from the Bible. What exactly
are these? I'll run through them briefly and
talk about them a little bit more
in more detail. Uh, emotion relation by which
is meant, umm, an ability to
respond to adversity, to negative events,
negative emotion and kinda reset your
emotional thermostat that you don't get sort
of bogged down in the negativity.
It's a way to respond -- it's basically a
coping mechanician in terms of your
emotional life and how you respond to things.
Decision making and all of the
things that go into decision making including
gathering knowledge, knowing what
knowledge to include in your decision, what
to -- not to include, how you gather
it, where you go to get it, where it accumulates
through the lifetime
experiences that we all have. Compassion,
by which is meant not simply feeling
for another person but taken almost to the
level of kind of mind reading where
you actually inhabit and understand another
person's point of view in order to
both understand what they're feeling, where
they're coming from, and how that
can inform a decision. Moral judgment and
reasoning, working through problems
that all of us encounter in a number of different
settings where we have to make
choices that are difficult precisely there
are good reasons to do either one.
Umm, patience by which is meant, uh, how do
we overcome the sort of impulse of
impatience when it doesn't serve us well?
How do we forestall immediate
gratification in order to achieve a larger,
if more distant, goal in time in
humility by which is not -- which is meant
not simply being humble but accepting
limitation as part of one's, uh, apparatus
that you don't -- will not have the
answers to everything, you will not be able
to find the answers to everything,
that sometimes you have to make decisions
without adequate information and also
I think there's a -- there's a component of
humility in making one's self
available to new sources or forms of information
that maybe did not conform to
what you expected or hoped so that it's an
openness to alternative forms of
knowledge that might be helpful ultimately.
Umm, altruism, a really important
component of what's now considered social
neural science. Actually, this idea
of sacrificing personal, uh, interest in the
greater interest and goals of an
group. Uh, sacrificing what you would want
in order to promote the goals of
this larger group whether it's a family, or
again, a company, whatever the group
happens to be. In this really important ability
to cope with uncertainty in
change, how do we -- you know, the world is
not static. The environment is not
static. It changes all the time. How do we
get upset by change or how do we
adapt to it? I hope you can se that each one
of these traits is not an island
virtue onto itself but rather that they feed
into and resonate with each other
so that being emotionally even-keeled effects
the kinds of decisions that you
make and compassion is not really feeling
for someone else, as I said, but
somehow inhabiting and understanding the point
of view of another person which,
again, in turn -- informs your decisions and
the decisions you take. So I set
out to see if I could find my interesting
brain science attached to these
components of wisdom and to see if the researchers
were willing to talk about
wisdom which, in some cases, surprisingly
they were. But I'll give you of many
examples of these neural pillars of wisdom
if you'll indulge another passage,
uh, from the -- from the book. In part I heard
from someone in -- at Google was
encouraging compassion meditation so it was
one of the reasons I wanted to, uh,
to read this. Umm, uh, let me -- I -- give
you a little brief introduction to
this passage. So one of the fundamental corner
stones of wisdom has always been
compassion and it's -- it's a central concept
that runs through Confusionism,
Buddhism, Judaic Christian tradition, umm,
the particle physicist Victor
Weisskopf famously once said, "Knowledge without
compassion is inhuman.
Compassion without knowledge is ineffective."
That's kind of an epigrammatic
intersection of compassion and science but
also a real intersection of
compassion and science. Umm, for more than
a decade, Richard Davidson, who's a
neuroscientists at the University of Wisconsin
has been flying in Buddhist monks
to Madison to do brain experiments. He measures
electrical activity in the
brain while they meditate or lie in an MRI
machine. Matthieu Ricard is a
French-born Buddhist monk who has participated
in a half dozen of these
experiments, uh, on compassion over the last
decade and I'd like to describe
just a bit of his visit, uh, on within of
these occasions. So at exactly 8:48
on an unseasonably brisk, overcast June morning
in Madison and with the hint of
rain in the air, Matthiue Ricard climbed out
of a Subaru Outback station wagon
driven by his friend Richard J Davidson license
plate "emote" adjusted his
saffron and purple robes over bare arms and
then sauntered into the Waisman
Center of Neuroscience for an arduous day
of meditation. Over the previous few
days, Ricard, a French-born Buddhist monk
who lives in a monastery in Katmandu,
had flown from New Delhi to Newark, led a
meditation workshop for financiers
from a Manhattan stock brokerage firm at the
Harvard Club, discussed a new book
project, and then traveled to Wisconsin, where
he has participated in
experiments since the year 2000. As he walked
down a long corridor, he paused
to hug old friends (he has come to Madison
half a dozen times for these
experiments) and greet people he'd never met
before, including a bemused
maintenance worker holding a paintbrush. Within
a few minutes he had slipped
out of his Top-Siders and settled his 62-year-old
frame onto a green pillow on
the floor of a small, dark, nominally soundproofed
booth. Then scientists
attached a hair net of a hundred and twenty-eight
electroencephalograph (EEG)
electrodes to his shaven skull. Each electrode
would measure electrical
activity in this Buddhist's brain as it meditated,
capturing any changes in
milliseconds while nearby computer monitors
would provide a running display of
the readings. (Neuroscientists prefer EEG
to MRI in certain situations or
certain situations -- or certain experiments
because the technique captures
instantaneous changes better than MRI.) C'est
bien, Matthieu? asked Antoine
Lutz, the French-born scientist leading the
experiment. Okay, Ricard replied.
With that, heavy door was closed, and the
experiment began. We have found a
correlation between a deep state of meditation
and change in the EEG activity of
the brain, explained Lutz, who published his
first monk data in a 2004 article
in the "Proceedings of the National Academy
Sciences", a leading international
journal. That study reported that expert meditators
who generated a state of
quote, unconditional loving-kindness and compassion,
end quote, (uh, which I
like to point out is a phrase that you do
not normally encounter in the
scientific literature. Uh, you now see it
in places like science and nature --
umm, uh, expert meditators who generated a
state of quote unconditional loving
kindness and compassion produced accompanying
changes in the brain, especially
something called gamma-band oscillations -- gamma-band
oscillations, about which
more in a moment. Now they are gathering more
data and asking expert meditators
like Ricard to estimate the intensity of their
mental states on a scale of one
to nine as their brain waves are being recorded.
Nearly an hour into the
experiment after segments devoted to the "focused
attention" and "open presence"
meditation, the voice of researcher Andy Francis
was piped into the little room.
"The next one will be compassion," he said.
According to the experimental plan,
Ricard would spend the next minute in "neutral"
not meditating at all to provide
a baseline brain activity. After a pause of
exactly 60 seconds, Francis leaned
toward his microphone and said in a flat,
neutral voice, "Compassion.
Compassion." At a scientific seminar in New
York several months earlier, Richie
Davidson had made the point that expert meditators
could turn it on like that
(which he indicated by snapping his fingers)
and although Ricard's compassion
meditation was not as instantaneous as snapped
fingers, it would probably strike
most people as impressively quick. After 15
seconds, he rated his meditative
state at two. By thirty seconds, he was up
to three. By 39 seconds he was up
to four. He reached five at the one-minute
mark and achieved a lofty seven at
two minutes. These are self-reported ratings,
of course, and deserving every
bit of skepticism that self-reports inevitably
invite. But since dedicating his
life to the practice of Buddhism in 1972 (literally
the day after he received a
Ph.D. in molecular biology in the Paris laboratory
of Nobel Laureate François
Jacob, Ricard has logged well over 10,000
hours of meditation and I couldn't
avoid the sense that I was watching a powerful
neural engine power up, roar, and
accelerate, like a race car, cognitively going
from zero to 60 in the figurative
snap of a finger. As Ricard's meditative state
deepened, the EEG readings
scrawling across Andy Francis' computer screen
visibly changed. At the
beginning, they had been a series of thin,
disorganized lines, the
electrophysiological equivalent of lank, unkempt
hair. By the time Ricard
reached a self-assessed eight, about seven
minutes into his compassion
meditation, the EEG readings had an intensity
of amplitude looking like bushy
eyebrows and an overall coherence and synchronicity
that were apparent, even to
my novice eye. "With a few practitioners,"
Francis explained, "you can see
change in the raw data in real time as they
meditate but that's very rare." At
the risk of sounding credulous (if not downright
corny), the electrical activity
measured by dozens of electrodes plastered
all over Ricard's noggin seemed in
remarkable harmony. Then the muffled sound
of a toilet flushing in a nearby
bathroom could be heard, and whether this
perturbed Ricard's meditative state or
not, his subjective ratings began to drop.
Later on in his office, Davidson
agreed that the coherence and synchrony of
these brain waves was so striking
that it is obvious even to nonexperts. "It
doesn't require any fancy computer
interpretation," he said. "I can actually
see it with the naked eye, so it's
pronounced." His current thinking (pure conjecture
at this point he conceded)
is that pattern of the brain activity observed
during meditation, known as
"gamma oscillation," might be a way for monks
to coordinate activity in
multiple parts of the brain while experiencing
intense compassion. "What is
striking about the gamma," Davidson said,
"is the synchrony across brain regions
that we see." From their own descriptions,
it's kind of a panoramic awareness
that's fused with compassion. But the elements
of the panoramic awareness
suggest that there are many different systems
in the brain that become
functionally integrated, which may be a neural
correlate of this experience of a
panoramic or vast awareness. A study by the
Wisconsin group, published in 2008
in the journal "Public Library of Science
One," reported that fMRI studies of
monks, and also novices, who followed a two-week
program of compassion
meditation written by Ricard -- showed increased
activity during compassion
meditation in several distinct parts of the
brain. Ricard emerged from the
chamber in Madison looking fresh and energetic
after the morning's experiments.
"You have to come to a lab to do meditation
these days," he said with a chuckle,
wiping his face with a towel. Umm, to kind
of wrap up and cut to the chase.
Umm, each of the middle chapters of the book
talks about one or another of these
neural properties associated with wisdom,
umm, and just to summarize very
quickly, there is a neuroscience of moral
judgment, there is a neural science of
emotion regulation, there is a neuroscience
of altruism now, there is a
neuroscience of decision making including
decisions in the face of uncertainty
and there is a neural science of delayed gratification.
And to cut even further
to the chase, when I started out pursuing
this hypothesis and began this become
back in 2007 there was no neuroscience of
wisdom. A month after I turned in a
draft of the book, uh, a review article appeared
in the journal "Archives of
General Psychology" which is a peer-review
journal, uh, and the title of that
article was "A Neural Biology of Wisdom."
Umm, it's not mainstream science at
this point but it's part of a conversation
that it was not part of, uh, even,
uh, two years ago. Umm, so at this point I'd
like to take any questions you
might have and, uh --
Host: Yeah. We'll take questions into the
microphone but first let's give
Steven a round of applause.
>> [Applause]
Stephen: Thank you very much.
Host: And, uh, if we do run out of time I'm
sure he'll be hanging out a little
afterwards to talk more or sign books if necessary.
So, again, use the mic if
you have a question. I'll start it out. Umm,
you know, wisdom, much like
consciousness in the mind for, you know, millennia
has been considered kind of
separate from the biological processes and
I know neural sciences, neural
biology really want to stitch those two strongly
together and remove any kind of
intangible higher mind. Did you -- were any
of those, uh, preconceived notions
you might have had broken or re-enforced or
just changed as you started to study
this? Did you actually believe in a distinct
mind before or do you more or less
now?
Stephen: I'm, uh, it's a synergistic question.
I guess I have two answers. As
the humanist my answer is, I think wisdom
is too big to, uh -- you know, for
science to entirely wrap its arms around.
As someone who's written about
science for 30 years, I've constantly been
surprised at how a reductive and
molecular nuts and bolt -- nuts and bolts
approach to issues has really changed
our thinking about how things work and how
even the mind functions. So, umm,
uh, I guess ill have an agnostic response
in the sense that a part of me thinks
this could be impossible ultimately to explain
everything about wisdom. I've
been constantly surprised by the ability of
science to explain things and I
think, uh, neuroscience, again, is a field
of the beginning of the story, not at
the end. Umm.
>> [Pause]
>> Umm, thanks very much for the talk. By
one of the things I thought of right
away was that, umm, the eight pillars seemed
to talk mostly about the abilities
to process information and things like that.
What about just the amount of
information? So kind of the size of the data
base for someone who is wise;
right?
Stephen: Uh-huh. Uh, I think one way you can
think about that is that as long
as your memory is functioning well, you're
building up a data base of lifetime
experience which is telling you, for example,
things about human nature as well
as a sort of, uh, factual knowledge base,
uh, and as long as you have the
ability to re-call that degree of information
in situation -- it's very
situational. One of the things about wisdom
that's interesting is that, uh,
what's a wise decision in one situation or
context will be foolish in another
because it needs -- it's very con textural,
umm, which is why it doesn't -- I
don't think it kind of fits any kind of algorithmic,
uh, notion of arriving at a
right decision. It really depends, uh, on
the context and the environment. And
when you think about this from a biological
point of view, umm, our environment
is never static and so, umm, it's a good idea
to design a brain that was very
flexible and adaptive to change because that's
the environment that we all live
in and that in fact all biological creatures
live in, uh, and this is such a
powerful instrument. I -- I think wisdom is
kind of, in part, being adaptive
and discerning enough to see when a situation
is changing or about to change and
then being adaptive to what that change means
and how you respond to it. So our
brains are -- are not built, umm, necessarily
for habit. Umm, there's been some
interesting experiments. You know, habit,
obviously is when you have the right
solution to the same problem that always comes
up. You do it quicker and more
efficiently but when the situation changes,
habit is engrained to the point
where people -- animals at least in experiments
that have a habitual response to
something have a harder time finding a different
solution. So you get ingrained
by habit and that actually impedes your ability
to find alternative solutions.
Neurologically, in animals, with a certain
set of experiments.
>> [Pause]
>> You -- you actually pretty early on in
the book up couple wisdom from
intelligence which I think that question was
kind of hinting at. How many backs
and how many things do you know is very different
from wisdom and -- and you
place wisdom within fairly easy reach of,
umm, of the color person. I mean,
[inaudible] you were talking about just give
us time most of us will be wiser
even if we're not wise when we're old, umm,
and some people, you know, are wise
beyond their years what have you but it didn't
-- it certainly didn't take away
any sort of elitist connotations when you
think about somebody who's very
intelligent and you kind of put wisdom kind
of at the back and it was almost
describing sort of a folksy sort of wisdom
which I don't necessarily agree with
the things that neuroscientists or that you
had laid out as, like, sure, those
are necessary but not sufficient.
Stephen: Mm hmm.
>> Umm, but, you know, could you talk about
what influenced that approach and
if there was kind of a sort of a populous
feel about it intentionally or if you
just really wanted to throw it out there?
Stephen: I wouldn't call it populous but I
would say -- I would frame it this
way. Umm, so much of intelligence is related
to cog -- it has traditionally
been related to cognition, obviously, so sort
of the cognitive part of
neuroscience has been focused on intelligence.
The whole, umm, aspect of
emotional intelligence has really been something
I'd say within the last 20
years or so, umm, this idea that there's other
inputs, other forms of knowledge
and so forth. Umm, I think a lot of that has
to do with negotiating the sort of
everyday dilemmas that people encounter and
I think when people think about
wisdom or even Solomonic wisdom, the classic
-- the local story of Solomon, it's
resolving this very immediate dilemma in a
very particular situation, how do you
do it? Umm, and so I think this emotional
intelligence, this idea of emotional
intelligence, uh, this attentiveness to what
emotion is doing in terms of
decision making and gathering information
and so on is part of, uh, I think what
your you're talking about is something that
everybody -- it doesn't require book
learning. It's more a -- a -- a learning kind
of -- again, the control of this
emotional thermostat in a way which I think
can be controlled with -- with, uh,
with use. I mean, the -- the -- the -- the
big, umm, take home message from
neuroscience in the last ten or 15 years is
this notion of plasticity, that
things change, umm, the brain changes on the
basis of experience or what you do,
uh, and even how you exert yourself and these,
uh, meditation experiments are
important because it shows that the brain
is changing when you're doing this
repetitive mental exercise or making this
mental exertion. Umm, I think what
that suggests is that even at the level of
this emotional content that this can
be, umm, uh, at least modulated. I think we
can learn to, you know, deal with
it at a certain level, modulate it, reduce
the -- the impact of negative, uh,
events or adversity through this kind of concentrated
practice and I really
think of it as, you know, if the 20 century
-- 20th century was a lot about
physical exertion and maintaining muscle tone
in terms of deeming ourselves fit,
I think the 21st century is going to be about
maintaining our mental tone by
mental exertion and really training our brains
in terms of dealing with some of
these things. We're not there yet, I would
hasten to add, clearly, but I think
it's really important.
Host: Well, since we are just about out of
time, I will finish with one last
question unless someone else has one they
wanna toss out there. Umm, so it's
kind of a cap -- again, you can always catch
Steven after the talk. So to cap
it all off, it actually makes -- you make
it sound as if, umm, you know, again,
wisdom -- the traits of wisdom could at least
if not be learned you can frame
them in your mind in such a way so it'd kind
of work faster towards that un
attainable goal of absolute wisdom --
Stephen: Mm hmm.
Host: -- and put yourself a little farther
down the road, little earlier on in
your life. Uh, is that a correct interpretation
that you actually could learn
certain aspects of wisdom or train your body
to -- to be ready for it in and if
so, any quick tips before you go?
Stephen: [Laughing]
Stephen: I'm always forced into say I don't
write self-help books. So I'm very
wary of making prescriptions. Uh, I think
one of the things you're eluding to
there's a discussion with this whole issue
of emotional, um, regulation, where
does that come from, where does it originate
and I talk about some
experimentation in the book that suggests
that maybe an early moderate exposure
to adversity or stress acts as a form of -- of
vaccination or inoculation where
it seems to enable, at least in animal experiments,
it seems to enable these
animals to deal -- deal with frustration and
difficult circumstances later on
indeed and enhance their problem solving abilities
in these very specific tasks
that they use in these experiments. Umm, I'm
certainly not suggesting that
children should be deliberately placed in
adverse circumstances as a way of
tuning this tissue but I think it's something
to be mindful of. There's a --
there's a history, umm, in terms of the major
figures of both philosophy and
religion, uh, of, umm, early life adversity
and people like Aristotle had a
speech impediment, was orphaned; Mosas had
a speech impediments; umm, the
Buddha, at least to some accounts, lost his
mother when he was seven days old;
umm, and through a number of other, uh, schools
of philosophy, Confucius lost
his mother -- or father when he was three;
Abraham Lincoln lost his mother when
he was nine. In other words, these are -- and
a number of founders of
philosophy were raised in what we would call
single-parent homes now. So
there's this kind of thread of an early life
adversity that may, uh, contribute
to this. I don't think we know enough to really
arrive at any kind of
prescription for it. Having said that, the
-- the most interesting exercise
that I got out of this whole thing was the
more I thought about and wrote about
wisdom, the more I just started asking myself,
what would be the wise thing to
do here when any kinda problem came up. And
as a kind of, you know, it's really
kind of an armchair mantra or amateur mantra
but by asking myself that question,
by stopping myself long enough to -- to ask
the question and begin to think of
what the possible answers might be I found
that I really useful exercise that I
think everyone could benefit from.
>> [Pause]
Stephen: And you don't need a prescription.
>> [Laughing]
Host: Well, once again, thanks Steven so much
for stopping by the San Francisco
office. One more round of applause for Steven
hall.
Stephen: Thank you very much.
>> [Applause]